take us through that process for you
adopting your own work well I mean of
course one of the things that's
different is is at least the implied
passage of time which in the book is is
more explicit I mean Ravens are very
cool to bring messages but they're not
as fast as like telegraph lines or or
Twitter they're not instantaneous so you
know you we establish the events
happening in King's Landing and its
downfall in imprisonment and and then
Sansa being coerced into writing this
letter and then next thing you know
Joffrey is getting the letter were of
course weeks have passed well the letter
was dispatched by Raven and the raven
made it made its way north you know it
takes a while and then the calling the
banners which you know that it goes from
the scene to to the banners are all
there and of course it takes it takes
quite a while for the for the banners to
assemble they each have to get that
raven they get the message they send out
the word to their own villages and there
of their sworn men and their feudal
under law under men and they assemble as
many men they can and then after march
great distances to Winterfell where the
Army is assembly you know and some of
this is established fairly clearly in
the books I mean that the chapter of the
Assembly of the army is told from brans
viewpoint and he's he sees Decorah
Starks coming in and other people were
there and we get the introduction to
many of the Lords while bran just simply
thinks about them well these at a car
start so they're from karhold and you
know the umbers are already here and the
sir wins were the first to arrive or
whatever he thinks about and you get the
introduction to these various families
and feudal houses and what the heraldry
is a lot of a lot of exposition but told
hopefully in an interesting manner from
from and filtered through brands
viewpoint when I first wrote this
adaptation I actually changed it
somewhat and I wrote a whole scene where
the banners fly off fish as you see and
then you see men getting the banners I
didn't try to do all all of the
principal
words of the north but I did some of the
ones who I thought would be important
characters like you you know you see
Roose Bolton and his mate maester is
delivering him a letter and you know
he's in the mid air in the midst of
fleeing someone but he he breaks off to
read the letter you know and you see the
great John Humber getting letter and
he's got his tanker to beer and yes at
war let's get together and go off you
know and the Karstarks are marching out
and you see mage more months fleet as
setting sail from bear islands and it
was a it was a whole it was a montage
there was no dialogue in it you know it
was just visual images of the of the
different places that we could you know
montages were always my weakness when I
was in Hollywood I would commit montage
at the drop of a hat it was very sad
maybe I just liked that word montage and
of course when when I submitted that
first draft and and David read it and
David Komiyama said George this this
montage is fabulous but it would realize
would cost five times our budget for the
entire season to do it here so you know
we won't do it that way all right just
have the Ravens fly out people will get
it that's the practicality of you know
of having to do these things you know
frequently dictates you know you have to
eliminate sequences or combine
characters or or imply things rather
than actually show things I mean I
noticed also that that first scene II
the arrival of King Robert you know the
Cersei's wheelhouse that you see coming
up again as a departure from the books I
mean in in the books the wheelhouse is
so big that it cannot fit inside
Winterfell the Gateway is too large for
it to get into the the courtyard is it's
like a giant medieval Winnebago with
like three stories that it takes like 40
horses to pull it down the road Cersei
is traveling in style and it's great but
of course it would have cost us a small
fortune to build a giant three-story
wheel house built
drawn by 40 horses or so so they they
found this you know gypsy thing or
whatever they have there and that's
pretty nice hold it like how's that feel
when you see those changes and you I can
only imagine thought about how that
can't go through the gates of Winterfell
what that would actually be like and
then it ends up being a gypsy thing you
know it feels okay because I understand
the process and I understand why these
choices are made I think I was in a
unique position coming to this whole
thing because of the ten years that I
did spend in television the film I was
on the other side of this process I know
tomorrow we're doing the the master
class here at TIFF where I'll be talking
to some film students and so forth I
will be showing some of the older shows
that I worked on had a role in that
I remember the the very first thing of
mine that was ever filmed was a episode
of Twilight Zone to CBS revival Twilight
Zone the in the mid mid 80s called the
last defender of Camelot and it was it
was an adaptation of the classic Roger
Zelazny short story which I had done and
Roger Zelazny was one of my closest
friends he also lived in Santa Fe I
loved Roger I loved his work so when I
got this assignment to adapt his story
which I had brought to their attention
and said this will make a great Twilight
Zone episode you know my idea was to do
an absolutely faithful adaptation to to
just take Rogers story and adapt it
perfectly because you know Hollywood was
always messing up things and I wasn't
going to do that especially not for my
friends story and then of course I get
into the process and and I find myself
making these changes some for good
reasons some for not-so-good reasons and
it was a it was a very important
educational experience for me it
I'll give you two examples if we have
the time she wants to go into it from
that particular episode I don't know if
any of you have ever seen the last
defender of Camelot or or read the story
this is a story about Sir Lancelot who
is still alive he has lived to the
present day and
you know he gets approached by Morgan la
Fey who sends two thugs to assault him
and she's still alive too
she's also lived to the present and she
says Merlyn is about to wake up
he's been asleep in a cave all these
years so Lancelot goes to see Merlin and
Merlin wakes up and you we realised that
Merlin has this whole plan to restore
Camelot
but Lancelot is trying to say well we
don't really need a like a god-given
king anymore we have like democracy now
things have changed they vote on their
leaders oh well we'll put an end to that
says Merlin and so Lancelot winds up
battling him it's a it's a great story
it's full of wonderful Roger Zelazny
stuff and at the end of it there's a
there's a gigantic battle where Lancelot
has to fight
Merlin's enchanted champion who's a
magical suit of armor the hollow knight
is just the armor there's no one inside
the armor and they fight in sort of an
otherworldly Stonehenge it looks like
Stonehenge but of course it's bigger and
there's a ethereal mist around it and
all that and they're on horses and their
fart fighting and charging with swords
and Lance's and stuff like that and I
wrote it all like that in the first in
the first draft so and then we go into
production and and the line producer
comes to me and says okay George you can
have Stonehenge or you can have horses
but you cannot have horses and because
if we build Stonehenge we're gonna build
it on the soundstage it's gonna be made
of paper mache and the horses galloping
on the wooden floor design stage will
shake the giant rocks then they'll fall
over and it won't look good at all no or
if you want two horses then we'll film
it on location and but we won't be able
to build a stonehenge because the wind
would just blow it over because they're
they're just false fronts and all that
so you have to make your choice and I
was in agony over the story you know so
I actually called up Roger and said
Roger I'm sorry I'm sorry I apologize so
much but what they said I could
still niche what do you want yeah and
Stonehenge so we we had Stonehenge and
no horses and and they had sword fight
on foot and it worked fine it was good
so that's the sort of example that I
think is you can make in an adaptation
it's made for logical reasons having to
do with budget and realities however
there was also another change that
occurred in that episode which to this
day I regret that I may die you know but
I was brand new and I didn't you know I
didn't fight enough for it you know
think about working for the traditional
networks is they've got this idea in the
head that every show has a formula you
know and and high-concept and when you
pitched a pilot it has to fit it you
know like my friend Mike Cassatt came up
with this the classic formula years ago
for the pitcher that he's the Pope she's
a chimp they fight crime there it is
three word high concept for a TV show
the pontiff in the primate coming soon
to your network so the network was
always a little uneasy about twilight
zone because it didn't have a little
formula was anthology show every episode
was different every other episode but
they managed to come up with one
nonetheless then the network came up
with this no okay we figured out what
Twilight Zone
Twilight Zone is an ordinary man finds
himself in in the extraordinary
situation so okay that's great
so I pitch them bless defender of
Camelot and I write the script and we're
going into production right and suddenly
we're casting the role and suddenly we
get a panicked call from the network
wait wait wait we can't go ahead with
this episode we've just realized there's
no ordinary man in it the main
characters are Merlin Lancelot and
Morgan la Fey where's the ordinary man I
mean Twilight Zone has to be about an
ordinary man and this is Lancelot he's
lived forever you know he's not ordinary
he's a great hero so in the opening
scene of the show you know Lancelot is
attacked by these two thugs
because Morgan la Fey wants to see him
and the idea is that she's hired two
thugs they're just street thugs they're
gonna beat him up and take him to Morgan
Maffei and she's gonna tell him what's
going on because their ancient enemy she
didn't think you know polite message
Morgan la Fey would like to see you
would work so you know that worked
further refine the story so what I had
to do was keep one of those one of the
thugs is like a young innocent kid named
Tom and I had to keep Tom around for the
rest of the whole goddamn story
an ordinary man who would be there he
doesn't do anything in the story sort of
tags around would Lancelot saying gosh
wow this is strange my god a wizard
stuff that you hate to see it an
adaptation because it's all wrong it's
it's for the wrong reason since the
network has this stupid idea about what
the formula is and they kind of impose
it on you and that's the sort of
nonsense you get sometimes that you know
can mess up a show when they're trying
to fit it into something but the episode
turned out alright and Roger liked it so